let's go next to why don't we go? Oh, I don't
know. There's just so many people. Let's go
to Christopher from Houston, Texas, to Christopher
from Houston. What's going on?
Thank you, Chairman.
I can you're the voice is coming through very
oddly, but I can hear you, OK?
I'm talking to my fourth person right now.
So now I believe Ford Fusion is one of the
latest vehicles that is going from being available
in a stick shift to automatic only. Is that
is that correct?
I got to tell you, I'm not always beautiful.
I love it.
All right, so I'm I'm a physical therapist,
a doctor, a physical therapist, and I'm a
doctor. I do hope it helps. So, you know,
I go to people's houses and, you know, help
them out in the home after they got home from
the hospital. Yeah. And I just wanted to kind
of give kind of a ground report of what it's
like in rural Texas before the election. Like
every you know, Fox News is on full blast
all the time, you know, and then now we're
like 50 50 Newsmax and Fox News website.
So now let me ask you this.
This is this is so this is such a dumb question
in the sense that I should know this, but
I only consume any of this stuff online. Is
Newsmax on regular cable for people or is
it only on satellite? How do you. I'm only
familiar with getting news, Max, on the computer.
Is it part of people's cable packages down
there?
I I really have no idea, but maybe maybe I
got you some, you know, Internet going on,
but I'm not exactly sure.
I just noticed that, you know, they're on
their TVs while I'm trying to do therapy and
I tell them to mute the TV because I can't
hear my own hair metal and have have any of
the people that you're you're working with,
do they let slip bonkers conspiracy theories
that they would have gotten from Newsmax?
Oh, absolutely. Like so I could act undercover.
While I'm working with them, you know, they'd
be like, oh, yeah, that's crazy.
Like, totally the Democrats or, you know,
basically bought off by China and everything,
blah, blah, blah.
It's just kind of, oh, you play a little play
along in other words.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, if they don't
agree with me, it's harder for me to work
with them to get therapy and all that. I understand
that.
It's kind of interesting to see the range
of opinions out in rural Texas.
All right. Well, listen, I don't envy you
and keep up the good work and let's let's
hope things improve.
All right. Thanks. I love the show.
All right. Thanks very much. Wow. Yeah, that
sounds that sounds pretty, pretty bonkers.